all right dozens of you sent me the
video I'm about to play and this story
and I'm going to present the story to
you as best as I understand it there is
a video that has gone completely viral
of a guy wearing an oxygen mask that
people said David this guy is an
American who faked his death he's
pretending to be Irish with an obviously
fake accent and covering his face with
an oxygen mask this is a completely
insane situation so before we play the
video I'm going to do my best to explain
to you what this is all about there's an
independent article called fugitive
accused of Faking his own death sobs as
he insists I'm an Irish orphan okay
Nicholas Rossi also known as Nicholas
alaverdian appeared on ustv claiming
mistaken identity
he is a suspected rapist said to have
faked his own death while on the run
from the FBI and living in Scotland and
he appeared on NBC's Dateline
and he was confronted and told you know
people believe you are Nicholas
oliverdian and it all completely
exploded he's 35 years old he now wears
an oxygen mask in public again it's
unclear whether it's for a medical
reason or to hide his face he claims to
be Irish orphan Arthur Knight a victim
of mistaken identity who has never
stepped foot in the United States of
America last November uh Sheriff Norman
McFadden fadian ruled that Rossi was the
man U.S authorities were seeking but he
says he's just a different person if you
look at the Wiki page about this
um it says indeed Nicholas aliverti and
known as Nicholas Rossi and Arthur
Knight is an American sex offender who
faked his own death in 2020. so I'm
going to play the video for you here
I hope I now am getting the details
right this is a guy who says I'm an
Irish orphan
but in reality is an American who faked
his own death I believe to avoid
uh uh legal trouble okay check this this
this is I've never seen anything like
this
we were once a normal family but thanks
to the media our lives have been
interrupted
and we like privacy and I would like to
go back to being a normal husband now
one of the weird things is
he I guess claims to be Irish
but I don't think that's actually an
Irish accent that sounds like sort of a
British accent which is a strange detail
for sure but I can't because I can't
breathe I can't walk people say that's
not let me try to stand up let me try to
stand up so he tries to he I guess tries
to stand up and again it's unclear
whether the being unable to walk is part
of the disguise as well I just don't
know
he sort of quote tries to stand up and
the person who's with him
um I think I think it's a woman who's
with him kind of like uh reacts like oh
no I've got to save this guy exactly
exactly what do you say to to someone
who believes that that you are Nicholas
salivarian
Andrea I am not Nicholas
and I do not know how to make this clear
what do you say to people who say these
are crocodile tears he's putting on a
show this is all an act
oh thank you
and the woman on the left is treating
him like he's a crying seven-year-old
boy it's all completely Bonkers so at
some point maybe we'll know more but the
best assessment I have of this I mean
this this is a story that
it it went viral if we weren't living in
such insane times as we find ourselves
living in right now this would have gone
even more viral like without even a
shadow of a doubt this is completely
Bonkers and again I don't know if the I
think he's in a wheelchair
oxygen mask dark rimmed glasses
claiming to be Irish while speaking in a
British accent I think that that's all
part of the disguise but I have never
seen anything like this not a criminal
genius I think is fair to say and I'm
struggling to believe that this is
actually an Irish orphan insane story
let me know what you think about it one
of our sponsors is short form short form
makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and Paul politics to
science and health I was recently
checking out James clear's Atomic habits
on short form of course they have the
guide but they also have highlights they
also include other similar books about
habits and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a
summary of the book there are new guides
and articles released every week and
short form is giving my audience a free
trial plus 25 off a subscription which
is a fifty dollar value so for the price
of a book per month you get access to
thousands go to shortform.com Pacman the
link is down below